y la extracción del apéndice denominada
apendicectomía se lleva a cabo cuando se
sospecha la existencia de una
apendicitis dolor en el cuadrante
inferior derecho del abdomen fiebre y un
recuento elevado de glóbulos blancos son
síntomas y signos comunes de apendicitis
los que generalmente aparecen cuando
existe una obstrucción entre el apéndice
y el intestino esto puede ocasionar
infección hinchazón y distensión si el
apéndice no se extrae puede producirse
una ruptura o perforación con riesgo de
muerte el único tratamiento para la
apendicitis es la apendicectomía que
casi siempre se realiza en casos de
emergencia las técnicas laparoscópicas
más recientes requieren solo incisiones
mínimas en forma de ojo de cerradura o
pequeñas incisiones punzantes lo que
generalmente da por resultado un periodo
de recuperación más corto
antes de la cirugía se le colocará una
vía endovenosa las apendicectomías se
realizan con anestesia general por lo
tanto estará dormido durante el tiempo
que lleve la operación se insertará
temporalmente un tubo respiratorio por
la boca y hacia la garganta para
ayudarlo a respirar durante la operación
además también puede colocarse un
catéter en la vejiga para drenar la
orina
generalmente una apendicectomía
laparoscópica sin complicaciones lleva
entre 20 y 30 minutos para poder acceder
al apéndice su cirujano utilizará
instrumentos cortantes denominados
trócares para crear tres orificios
pequeños o puertos de entrada a través
de la pared abdominal generalmente estos
puertos de entrada se encuentran a nivel
umbilical y en los cuadrantes izquierdo
inferior y derecho superior del abdomen
luego se bombeará dióxido de carbono a
través de los puertos de entrada
umbilical para inflar el abdomen y así
poder visualizar su contenido más
fácilmente
luego el cirujano insertará el
laparoscopio a través del puerto de
entrada umbilical las imágenes de la
cámara se proyectan en un monitor de la
sala de operaciones
el cirujano examinará minuciosamente el
interior del abdomen y confirmará si el
apéndice está rojo hinchado y necesita
ser extirpado en este momento es
cirujano introducirá los instrumentos
quirúrgicos por los otros dos puertos
tomará el apéndice lo separará del
intestino lo colocará en una bolsa para
muestras y retirará la bolsa a través de
uno de los puertos
después de extraer el apéndice de forma
segura el cirujano instalará solución
salina estéril tibia en el abdomen a
través de uno de los puertos para
enjuagar la cavidad abdominal y eliminar
todo rastro de infección
luego se succiona la solución salina
antes de retirar el laparoscopio el
cirujano observará por última vez la
zona en busca de sangrado u otro daño
cuando se retire laparoscopio se deja en
el lugar una válvula del puerto por poco
tiempo para liberar todo el dióxido de
carbono del abdomen
finalmente las incisiones en forma de
ojo de cerradura se cierran con suturas
o grapas y se cubren con vendaje
al finalizar la cirugía se le retirarán
el tubo respiratorio y el catéter se lo
llevará al área de recuperación para
monitorearlo y se le proporcionarán
medicamentos para el dolor según sea
necesario cuando puede ingerir líquidos
se le retirará la vía endovenosa la
mayoría de los pacientes son dados de
alta dentro de las 24 horas